All right.
This has gone too far.
Let's take a step back.
Hello world,
it's Saroj and the blockchain space has been plagued with scams,
apps with bad user experiences and some major technical issues.
I'm going to talk about what's gone wrong in the space,
what's gone right.
Then give some insight into how this technology will evolve in 2019 using
programmatic examples for context.
Two years ago I wrote a book called decentralized applications harnessing
Bitcoin's blockchain technology.
I also this year taught a 10 week course titled decentralized applications at
School of Ai.
Clearly I've been very excited about the potential for this technology,
but if we bring up Google and type in Bitcoin,
the first ever cryptocurrency created,
all of the results are about it's price.
They are debating whether or not it's a good investment opportunity and all of
this is coming from mainstream organizations that have big distribution
channels,
so they're framing how the public thinks about bitcoin.
Symbio it's are an endangered species invest in venom coin
and it of course can be,
but that's not the real value of this technology.
Let me explain.
The bitcoin network stores all of its transactions in a database.
This database is distributed.
Each node in the network stores a copy of it,
and this database is arranged in sequential block objects that each store
transaction signatures linked together via pointers to form a chain,
Aka a block chain.
Certain nodes called miners use their computers to convert kinetic energy in the
form of electricity into a ledger block.
And this distributed mining machine repeatedly performs operations until it
solves a really simple math puzzle.
The result,
a single hash,
which itself takes very little energy to compute,
is a direct representation of the huge ball of energy that was required to
produce it.
It's a mathematical proof that the block was minted.
Therefore,
an attacker wanting to modify any of this transaction data maliciously would
need to have more computing power than half the network to do so.
And even if this attacker used all of the super computers in the world combined,
it still wouldn't be enough.
Since bitcoin is such a massive network,
that's why it's still intact.
A decade later.
The bitcoin network enabled trust and cooperation between humans at a scale
never seen before,
specifically around securing and maintaining its ledger.
And this model of trust is built on math and physics,
mainly the proof of work algorithm.
Institutional Trust has been the predominant model of trust today,
but it's not perfect.
The Equifax hack,
the wells Fargo scandal,
the drama over user data at Facebook,
Dunkin donuts in India.
These are just a few examples of how institutional trust has bailed us trust
based on math and physics helped ensure that astronauts could land on the moon
safely and we can also use it to guarantee that no one can modify bitcoins
bookkeeping record.
This is an incredibly powerful idea.
If this trust is based on math and physics,
it's programmable.
We can engineer entirely new incentive structures.
Maybe we can incentivize people not to merely mind blocks,
but to do social good for the world,
to volunteer to help make the lives of other humans better in ways that were
previously not profitable.
We could also incentivize them to store files,
share computing power,
collaborate in all sorts of novel ways.
It coin was the first decentralized application or dap.
In my book,
I talked about a new business model where users could get paid by apps specific
tokens for their contributions and they could use these app tokens to access
certain features.
If the APP was successful,
these tokens would accrue in value over time.
This idea was later dubbed initial coin offerings or ics and it became the
defacto way that any decentralized startup raise money and just a few lines of
code most often done on a blockchain network called etherium.
Anyone could create a new market issuing a set of tokens to people globally.
They could raise money not from venture capitalists but from the crowd.
The problem with the ICO model is that we've seen so many low quality proof of
concepts,
meaning during the public sale,
lots of these startups only have a white paper and a website,
no code.
It was perverted from an innovative way to raise startup capital without selling
your soul to venture capitalists to how fast can we scam a whole generation of
crypto suckers out of their money before regulators catch us every time some
scammer gets caught.
I imagined the yacht seen from wolf of Wall Street.
I've watched it like 500 times.
I was,
however glad to see a surge in new dapps being created at least a thousand of
them in the past few years,
but on almost every dimension,
they are worse than their centralized counterparts.
Decentralized apps are slower,
there are more expensive,
less capable,
have worse user experiences.
They have volatile and uncertain governance.
They are not a pleasure to use as much as I'd like them to be except for Crypto
kitties and that's because there are certain structural tradeoffs that results
directly from the primary design goal of these services that's prioritized above
all others.
Decentralization,
we need only look back at the history of the Internet to see the parallels
between the rise of the early web and this new decentralized web.
The dotcom bubble was caused by crazy high valuations,
ill informed speculation and Utopian promises of a better future.
If there's one takeaway we should have from that era,
it's that digital networks and code aren't a solution to human brokenness.
Instead of leading us to truth,
the Internet gave us all an opportunity to build our own personal knowledge
universe,
which catalyze a detachment in society from actual fact that has led to the rise
of propaganda fed authoritarianism globally.
Instead of freeing ourselves from the manipulation of corporations and
governments,
the Internet became the most powerful tool of surveillance,
behavioral manipulation and control ever created in human history.
We should hold onto our idealism.
As developers,
we're building this new world and the code we write,
the applications we build will deeply affect the future of humanity,
but we need to be careful to not fall victim to the same exact fallacies that
are hacker forebearers embraced in the 90s we've learned a lot in this past
decade about what doesn't work so far.
It's not decentralization,
but convenience.
That's been the commodity our generation values the most.
In fact,
we value convenience so much that we choose to use services like Amazon despite
how it treats its workers and despite how it's becoming increasingly pervasive
in every aspect of our lives.
But it turns out that there is a growing trend of distrust towards centralized
everything over the past few years,
and that is now starting to include the biggest tech companies.
Data regulation laws are being enacted across the world and people are waking up
too many problems with centralized services.
We shouldn't be building more trust,
less systems.
Instead,
we should be building more trust,
full systems systems that allow us to more easily trust other humans.
Trust isn't something that we need to remove the need for.
It's something to strengthen with technology.
It's going to take a societal shift in consciousness towards valuing things like
privacy,
data ownership,
and algorithmic transparency.
But that's not hard to imagine.
Until recently,
encrypted messaging was only used by hackers,
spies and this guy,
but in the post Snowden era,
everyone seems to be using signal or telegram.
WHATSAPP is end to end encrypted.
The press solicit tips through secure drop,
and of course the technology improved,
but it's mainly changes in society that drove that adoption.
Humans will deploy any technology for both good and evil for the realization of
freedom and tyranny for charity and for greed.
So let's move fast and iterate on what we've learned.
To begin,
let's all start using the term distributed ledger technology or DLT instead of
blockchain.
The Enterprise has already started to adopt that term.
It's less triggering and more generalized a term.
It pushes away from blockchains association with the wild west of crypto in ics.
Next,
I want to demonstrate for real world uses of this technology that profitable
businesses have already been built on in finance,
medicine,
manufacturing,
and government.
Let's start with finance.
Over 2 billion people in the developing world remain unbanked.
That's one in every five adults,
financial inclusion is considered a key factor in poverty reduction.
The unbanked population of global utilities customers has gone largely
unrecognized.
They've been left to wait in line at local utility offices to make payments in
hard currency,
often in uncomfortable and unsafe areas.
This all feeds into a cycle of poverty,
disabling them from financial stability and thus stoking the fires of political
instability.
But humanic is a startup using DLT to create an identifiable bank account for
any human in the cloud.
That's one piece of the financial inclusivity puzzle.
Next comes credit services like bloom are being used as a basis for risk
assessment and credit scoring.
This allows people to gain access to their credit worthiness and lets them use
credit cards.
It tracks a user's credit score over time to verify who is safe debt or could be
by using DLT.
Biblio graph allows people to save,
transfer and invest their wealth.
Creating a cycle of wealth generation.
There are so many processes and services that our bank provides and we can
decouple each of those and turn each of them into standalone businesses that can
provide financial inclusion for people in the developing world.
Next is medicine ever wonder why you have to fill out a new form every time you
see a new doctor.
Most healthcare is provided by separate independent practices without efficient
methods of communicating with each other.
We could store that data on a server but controlled by who medical data is
sensitive.
Encrypting it and storing it on a DLT empowers patients with a self sovereign
health identity,
a global holistic record of encrypted medical data that can be shared between
any health provider you choose.
That's what meant health is working on it's tamper proof since the lts are
immutable technology so the patient doesn't have to worry and this idea of
sharing data between multiple parties that don't know each other can be applied
to any kind of supply chain.
In a typical supply chain scenario,
there are multiple independent parties that take some payload from point a to
point B and there has to be a way to keep track of it all.
An Independent tamperproof ledger that records where and when some product has
been delivered is what a DLT can uniquely provide.
Suku is doing just that and efficient,
transparent and collaborative bash board that let's each party see where the
product is in whichever industry.
And just last month,
West Virginia became the first state in the u s to allow people to vote online
using a DLT in a federal election,
piloting the program for military and other voters living overseas by partnering
with the Boston based Startup called votes.
The APP works by recording boats on the ledger.
Then facial recognition tech verifies the voters identity by comparing it to a
driver's license or other photo id.
And their vote is recorded on the ledger where each is mathematically proven.
Anyone can vote from anywhere in the world with no potential for human error.
Since it's tamper proof,
144 West Virginia voters stationed in 30 countries cast their ballots with boats
for the 2018 midterm election.
The ICO model is already evolving into Iti or equity token offerings and an Eto
investors are issued actual equity tokens which give them an unparalleled level
of legal protection by providing them rights.
Similar to equities.
This means far less scamming.
Scalability is definitely an issue,
but vitalic Scott,
some really cool ideas involving quadratic sharding.
He wants it theory.
I'm to be operating at visa levels and three years.
Using it.
Sharding means splitting the entire states of the network into a bunch of
partitions called shards that contain their own independent piece of states and
transaction history.
Certain nodes would process transactions only for certain shards,
allowing the throughputs of transactions processed in total across all shards to
be much higher than the current standard and wild bitcoin is definitely slow.
It's still an immutable ledger side chains that use faster consensus mechanisms
like proof of stake can be pegged to bitcoin allowing for a second layer of
operability.
This is something that developers in this space are excited to have fully
developed in 2019 using side chains,
we can take advantage of bitcoins,
immutability and decentralization,
avoid its volatility,
and also leverage the speed of a much faster consensus mechanism on a different,
the Lt.
Overall.
Three things to remember from this video.
The distributed ledger technology space is still evolving.
We've learned a lot from ICO scams and subpar decentralized apps.
There are profitable businesses using DLT out there right now providing
financial services to the developing world and in a few other fields.
And moving forward we can focus on scaling solutions like quadratic sharding and
proof of stake side chain to Bitcoin to create the depths of the future.
Where do you think blockchain is going?
Let me know in the comment section and please subscribe for more programming
videos.
For now,
I've got to use my bank,
so thanks for watching.